روسيا تكشر عن انيابها وترمي بورقه
الصواريخ الفرط صوتيه فالعنوان الابرز
للهجمات الروسيه الاخيره هو استخدامها
صواريخ كينجال الفرط صوتيه وهي صواريخ
تمثل فخرا لصناعه الروسيه
استخدام موسكو لهذه الصواريخ لاول مره منذ
بدايه الحرب دق ناقوس الخطر داخل المعسكر
الغربي فهذه الصواريخ فاجات الولايات
المتحده بحسب صحيفه واشنطن بوست سيما وان
انظمه الدفاع الجوي التي سلمتها واشنطن لم
تستطع التعرف على هذه الصواريخ او
اكتشافها وبالتالي لم يتم اعتراضها فما هي
مواصفات صاروخ كينجال الذي سرق الانظار في
ساحه المعركه هو صاروخ فرط صوتي ذو قدرات
نوويه وتصل سرعته الى 12 الف كيلو متر في
الساعه اي تفوق سرعته سرعه الصوت بمقدار
تسع مرات كما انه يستطيع اصابه اهداف على
مدى اكثر من 2000 كيلومتر ولديه قدره
هائله على اصابه الاهداف حيث ان هامش
الخطا فيه لا يتعدى مترا واحدا دون ان
ننسى قدراته على تخطي انظمه الدفاع الجوي
موسكو وجهت رسائل ع من خلال الهجوم
بصواريخ كينجال اهمها تذكير الغربي
بقدراتها العسكريه العاليه وهذا ما تحدثت
عنه صحيفه واشنطن دائما التي اعتبرت ان
هذا الهجوم يعكس ضعف الغرب وخاصه الولايات
المتحده التي لا تمتلك صاروخا بنفس
المواصفات فروسيا تعد اكثر دوله متقدمه في
مجال الصواريخ الفرد صوتيه تليها الصين
التي تطور هذه التكنولوجيا بوتيره متسارعه
وذلك بحسب الكونجرس الامريكي
صاروخ كنجال اذا ليس سوى غيض من فيض تقول
روسيا التي لا تزال تملك المزيد وسام
الذهبي العربيه